is it kind of an amazing thing I know
you've probably been asked this a
million times but to be a part of
something so monumental like so
important in pop culture like everyone
rushed on Thursday nights to watch that
show like we literally everyone I know
watched it like that's it's funny now I
mean if it felt really huge but the way
things are now with like social media
and streaming and your ability to binge
watch something that was back before
they get VCRs back then yeah nobody knew
how to do wait yeah but nobody could
figure out how to tape a show I do right
there you can press record but like to
the program and you've got the news yeah
but now it's a its it feels somehow just
as relevant now is it as it did back
then yeah it's it's funny because we're
all so much older now you know what I
mean then you mean it's on TV you think
god look at Liz so young and then you
come on I feel like that was my career
as well um could you leave the house
though back in the height of height of
it all cuz I remember we were actually
both at the same award I can't remember
what it was but it was during American
Idol and y'all were a couple of y'all
were there and everybody was swarming
around y'all and so I was like oh my god
that's gotta be rough yeah well you know
there's some weird things that happened
you know back back then I remember one
time so it was during the week I was an
ass it was just like during the
afternoon I'd be flipping channels I was
watching the news and for some reason
they had like a split screen on the TV
six quadrants wouldn't be quadrants but
six and each was a live shot of each one
of our houses like a helicopter shot
they've casted friends houses and I was
like okay what what is this what's going
on here and I'm watching it was like a
not there was no information and no news
really just showing the houses and we're
looking close at my house and thinking I
need a new roof so the helicopter flies
away I get the ladder out subscribe to
my channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel please don't make me keep going